son ingérence dans la campagne
présidentielle américaine n'est plus à
prouver
il s'agit du coronavirus le sujet est
même devenu un véritable enjeu politique
entre les républicains et les démocrates
chaque camp tente de discréditer l'autre
sur cette problématique
côté byden l'accent est mis sur le bilan
humain de la crise sanitaire
une crise gérée par un président qui
s'est longtemps montré réticent à porter
un masque est pour le moins sceptique
sur les recommandations des instances
médicales internationales
les experts nous disent que nous allons
perdre près de 200 notre vie dans tout
le pays au cours des prochains mois tout
cela parce que ce président se soucie
plus de la bourse que de vous parce
qu'ils refusent de suivre la science on
estime que si nous portions juste un
masque juste un masque au cours des
prochains mois des experts de sa propre
administration disent que nous pourrions
sauver 100 mille vies côté donald trump
la meilleure défense reste la contre
attaque
ils l'affirment la pandémie est un écran
de fumée
utilisé à des fins électoralistes par
les démocrates pour lui nuire
ils ont fait durer la pandémie c'est
tout ce dont j'entends parler maintenant
c'est tout ce que j'entends vous allumez
la télévision kovi kovi kovi kovi kovi
d' un avion s'écrase 500 personnes sont
mortes
il n'en parle pas kovi kovi kovi des
eaux fait le 4 novembre vous n'entendrez
plus parler
c'est vrai qu'au lead qu'ovide ne
sortait pas voter s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît ne sortez en aucun cas pour
voter joe biden est surnommé sleepy joe
joe lando remis par son adversaire
républicain
une image de candidat vieillissant et
poussiéreux que donald trump martèle
depuis le début de la campagne
alors ce samedi le camp bayonne joue la
carte du dynamisme avec l'intervention
d'un ex-président sourire aux lèvres et
manches retroussées devant les
sympathisants démocrates venus l'écouter
cette pandémie aurait été difficile à
gérer pour n'importe quel président car
nous n'avons pas vu une telle chose
depuis 100 ans mais l'idée que cette
maison blanche effet haute
chose que complètement foiré et absurde
en attendant le 3 novembre plus de 55
millions d'américains ont déjà voté de
manière anticipée dont le président
sortant
le coc vide restera sans doute un enjeu
politique majeur après l'élection aussi
le virus a déjà tué près de 225 mille
personnes dans le pays